they talk to me about it but the problem
was they didn't have a script or a new
character they just said trust us we'll
create one it's all to do with a very
tight time schedule that American
television seems to work on you know
they have to start in September or
whatever it is and they have that
upfront snore I think it's very
difficult for me to consider this
without a script they said trust us
trust us trust us
yeah I said well you're obviously
brilliantly talented because I like that
show and yes they make brilliant TV
shows really but I said I'm too scared
to sign up without a script did you
watch it out of curiosity when they
brought in
you know Ashton Kutcher did you did you
want to see what the heck they had done
with this I did yes
yeah we did you have any regrets about
not trusting them on that well it was
still a very good show but what they
created fashion encryption it was
clearly something completely different
from what they were rated for me so it's
hard to judge but the money would have
been tremendous yeah it was it was
stratospheric yeah absolutely Stratos I
had no idea how much TV was worth here
yeah this guy I'm Simon Helberg who's in
Florence Foster Jenkins yeah when he
came over to work on the film I might
have been vaguely patronizing to him
because he hadn't done films before yeah
look at this gradually you realize not
only is the guy a much bigger star than
me he's maybe the richest man I've ever
met